bueno
ah
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta edición
especial de la entrevista en france 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es el
expresidente de ucrania petro poroshenko
que se comunica con nosotros desde las
calles de la capital ucraniana kiev ring
muchas gracias por estar hoy con
nosotros
es un placer ya gracias por ayudar a
ucrania entregar verdades sobre los
eventos en que viene un gran ya de
eliminación gracias
así que exactamente dónde se encuentra
usted y cuál es la situación y kiev
donde usted está ahora mismo estoy en el
centro de kiev
a unos 800 kilómetros de la frontera
gubernamental y a unos 12 km de las
tropas rusas
exactamente ahora están viendo que
tenemos una alerta de ataque aéreo
debido al bombardeo ruso
y como ustedes saben desde el 24 de
febrero
hoy es el quinto día de agresión
estos días hemos tenido misiles rusos
lanzando desde belarús y desde rusia
hemos tenido un ataque aéreo que ha
golpeado a ucrania y a los civiles
y desgraciadamente en estos cinco días
de guerra ya han muerto unos 500 civiles
está usted obligado a dormir en un
refugio como la mayoría de los
habitantes de la capital
no me estoy quedando en la oficina de mi
antiguo partido que ahora es la sede del
votación de la defensa territorial soy
parte de ese batallón
y lo estoy organizando y hoy hay muchos
habitantes de kiev personas específicas
que decidieron proteger nuestra nación
quiero agradecer el creciente apoyo
occidental que llega al cráneo en el
momento quizás más difícil de nuestra
historia
esto ocurrió desde el primer día e
incluso ahora de la invasión
de fuerte apoyo está deteniendo espero
el intento de putin de iniciar la
tercera guerra mundial
strong y estamos demostrando que no le
tenemos miedo a que no confiamos en
putin es débil cuando estamos
esta es una gran oportunidad para
demostrar que cuando estamos unidos
donde estamos dispuestos a presentar las
sanciones estamos dispuestos a estar
presentes
esto es extremadamente importante
quiero agradecerle a un muy buen amigo
de ucrania y amigo mío el que siente
makro el cáncer scholz a todos los
líderes de la unión europea que tomaron
una decisión muy importante
y que fue compartida por ursula von der
leyen que por primera vez en la historia
de la unión europea tomó la decisión de
pagar y entregarle a ucrania las armas
vitales que pueden detener la agresión
que pueden incrementar el precio que
pagan putin y rusia por invadir ucrania
porque putin ha lanzado una agresión no
solo contra ucrania sino que putin lanzó
una agresión contra la unión europea
contra francia contra todo es muy
posibilitado
pero nosotros aquí podemos estar tal vez
pagando el precio más alto pero estamos
protegiendo aquí también la libertad la
democracia
porque lo único que nos hace sufrir es
simplemente que queremos ser libres
queremos volver a la familia europea
y esta es la razón por la que pedimos
odio
señor por 80 le sorprende usted fue
presidente durante años y pidió más
apoyo europeo
muy rápidamente hubo duras sanciones y
ahora incluso hay armas que serán
enviados el jefe de política exterior de
la unión europea incluso mencionó
aviones de combate quiero decir esto es
bastante increíble solo en el espacio de
unos pocos días
no no estoy sorprendido estoy orgulloso
de que mi equipo y yo hayamos creado el
ejército ucraniano y estoy orgulloso de
la capacidad de defensa y la capacidad
de golpear a las tropas de putin
estamos demostrando y entregando la
evidencia de que ucrania tiene ahora uno
de los ejércitos más fuertes de europa
[Música]
y por eso por cierto es una decisión
absolutamente necesaria para presentarle
el plan de acción de ucrania a la otan
porque sería una cooperación de
beneficio mutuo porque con ucrania la
otan sería más fuerte
y creo que es muy importante que al
menos por primera vez en su historia
hubo la decisión de entregarle av tenía
aviones militares imaginen que 52
aviones y helicópteros de rusia fueron
golpeados y derrumbados por la fuerza
aérea ucraniana y misiles antiaéreos
definitivamente necesitamos esos misiles
definitivamente necesitamos estos
aviones
porque si no son derribados en ucrania
mañana aparecerán en el espacio aéreo de
cualquier nación europea
es
por esto es que definitivamente
necesitamos una zona de no vuelo en
ucrania
ucrania es una nación soberana tenemos
el derecho de prohibir la entrada a
nuestro espacio aéreo y esa será una de
las vías más efectivas para la seguridad
europea
y definitivamente necesitamos algunas
otras medidas que todavía estamos
esperando
acogemos con gran satisfacción la
decisión de ayer del consejo de la unión
europea porque definitivamente
necesitamos formar la adhesión de
ucrania a la unión europea
ucrania ya ha pagado un precio enorme
solo por la posibilidad de ser europea
definitivamente necesitamos que se le
otorgue a ucrania el estatus de
candidato ahora
eso sería una fuerte motivación para que
ucrania esté unida
se mantenga fuerte y coopere con la
unión europea
definitivamente necesitamos ahora lanzar
una negociación de anexión de forma
inmediata
esta es la respuesta correcta a putin
que no puede prohibir no volver a la
familia europea
también necesitamos los fondos de
recuperación ponemos a disposición de
ucrania ahora estamos en una situación
muy difícil
así que tenemos un plan absolutamente
claro y hoy en 20 minutos estaré en el
parlamento ucraniano en una reunión con
todo el gobierno del parlamento y
lanzaremos la solicitud de adhesión a la
unión europea y realmente pensamos que
la misma determinación que se demostró
ayer para las armas letales y el apoyo a
ucrania se mostrará entre todos los
estados miembros porque públicamente
dijeron que están apoyando
con esta situación creo que ucrania está
demostrando lo que significa golpear a
rusia
que putin esperaba que ucrania recibiera
a las tropas rusas con flores y en lugar
de flores las recibimos con un cóctel
molotov
lo que llamamos en ucrania banderas
mutis
panteras y muchos tanques rusos
portadores de armas rusos camiones rusos
tropas rusas
fueron golpeados y el número de rusos
que murieron durante los últimos cinco
días superó los cinco mil
esto es más fuerte que en chechenia esto
es más que en cualquier otra guerra con
rusia más que en siria o en cualquier
lugar
y esta es la forma en que juntos debemos
detener la rivalidad pero queremos la
paz
y
señor presidente hablando de paz se
supone que hoy habrá negociaciones entre
la delegación rusa y la ucraniana
tiene usted la esperanza de que esto
pueda conducir a un alto al fuego
pues usted bastante escéptico de que
pueda conducir algún tipo de solución al
menos temporal
durante los 5 años que fui presidente
tuve muchas negociaciones con rusia con
putin y a menudo llegamos a un acuerdo
no necesitamos nada extraordinario sólo
necesitamos cosas muy simples
en primer lugar necesitamos un alto al
fuego
en segundo lugar no queremos ningún
compromiso sobre la integridad del
territorio y la independencia de ucrania
[Música]
sólo tenemos una exigencia muy simple y
los rusos salgan de ucrania cualquier
otra cosa podemos discutir la
[Música]
cree que el señor putin está dispuesto a
hacer lo que se ha dado cuenta de que
puede haber calculado mal las cosas o
cree que intentará ejercer una presión
militar aún mayor en su país
creo que cometió muchos muchos errores
en primer lugar subestima la capacidad
de defensa del nuevo ejército ucraniano
que fue creado por los ucranianos porque
los planos están unidos los ucranianos
no están desmoralizados los ucranianos
están dispuestos a luchar
putin ex pueden esperaba una guerra
relámpago putin o incluso preparó el
comunicado de prensa desde el segundo
día empezando que ocuparían quien que
entrarían que eliminarían todo el
gobierno ucraniano y no les dimos
ninguna oportunidad y putin ya pagó un
precio enorme
en segundo lugar no esperaba que la
solidaridad con ucrania fuera tan fuerte
y que nuestros socios tales podrían
demostrar tal unidad al presentar las
misiones y
sanciones que ahora están destruyendo
completamente la economía rusa
las sanciones se están permitiendo que
cada ruso que apoya la matanza de
ucrania lo sientas en su propio bolsillo
porque la moneda rusa el rublo se ha
devaluado dos veces sobre el 50 por
ciento
y eso significa que los rusos se
empiezan a hacer dos veces más pobres y
esto es sólo el principio
la economía rusa puede colapsar el
pueblo ruso puede protestar contra putin
putin no tiene otra opción si quiere
mantener su país debe retirar las tropas
hacer un alto el fuego y tener una
negociación para la seguridad de rusia
nunca atacamos a rusia nunca lo tuvimos
en mente nunca haríamos eso
lo único que queremos es simplemente la
paz detener la guerra las tropas rusas
de ucrania
y hoy creo que el mundo entero está con
nosotros queremos aprovechar por cierto
esta oportunidad para dar las gracias al
pueblo francés al gobierno francés al
presidente ma chrome al presidente
online que han cooperado conmigo muy
estrechamente
y quiero agradecer a cada una de las
personas que participó en la
concentración de parís apoyando a
ucrania
quiero agradecer a la diáspora ucraniana
en parís por ser tan fuerte por
demostrar una solidaridad tan única son
grandiosos estamos juntos somos fuertes
lucharemos contra este agresor
muchas gracias y me activo coplas de
público
muchas gracias señor por cinco por
dedicar parte de su tiempo desde las
calles de kiev
y gracias por ver esta entrevista
exclusiva a quien france24
nuestra cobertura de la guerra en
ucrania continúa aquí en france 24 sigan
con nosotros
[Música]